first started enjoying my next guests
work in the great house of games back in
1987 your his collaboration with David
Mamet on stage as well as the silver
screen kicked off an amazing career that
is now part of the Criminal Minds
amazement that's going down with a 15th
and final season that airs tomorrow in
its premiere on CBS Wednesdays nights
the man the myth Joe Montaigne good to
see you here sir great to see rich you
got it 15 years is an absurd run you've
been on for 13 years of that right yeah
I started the show when my hair was
black you've gone full great huh yeah
you know it was like yeah it was like
you finally surrender you say Who am I
kidding you know it's like well you know
what I would love to have had that
option genetics had nothing to do with
you
so let's look before we go talk pop
culture let's talk about your bears what
do you think about the current state you
know being a Chicago sports fan period
is always kind of a trial you know what
I mean whatever whatever the sport I
mean the Bulls gave us that little brief
period of like wow hey we're hey we are
a sports town that's right you know we
are we are a city of winners yeah you
know but beyond that there's always
these these these periods whether it's
the Blackhawks the Cubs the Sox the
Bears where you go through the you know
the doldrums you go through those
periods and we're obviously kind of
entering and immerse them there well I
mean two years ago obviously last year
as a playoff season this year was a step
back yeah but it's always still you know
it's always close but no cigar kind of a
thing you'll get used to that they tease
you with it and it's such a great sports
town and that's what makes it even more
challenging but the Bears I mean look
you know I know there's a lot of
controversy about the quarterback then
you then you look back to you know we
went from Cutler
so we're do risky now risky yeah right
so that in itself was kind of a lot of
conversation about that what do you
think of Cutler ginger
I don't know saying I I never met the
guy I'm sure he's a wonderful human
being and all of that he's married to an
actress too he's comfortable with
somebody in the industry I saw this is
all good news just look at all the great
quarterbacks who I admired in my in my
life and I'm not the youngest getting in
a room here right and I think in none of
them played for the Chicago Bears so
when you think of the joe Montana's and
yeah Marino's in the Bradys and corners
go down the list so it'd be nice to be
able to say yeah there was that guy we
had have you ever been I guess in a
restaurant or whatever and people
thought Joe Montana was in the room oh
like I used to get a lot more and in the
day when Jill was actually active you
know but there one time I was making a
movie and I'm oh and I'm in my trailer
location wherever it was it was a knock
on the door and I opened the trailer
door and there was a kid standing there
with a football and he's got this look
on his face you know somebody had told
him hey who's there making movies on the
street who's in it Joe might change oh
let me go get the football and so I
didn't know what to do i disappoint the
kid by torso just sign it and say yeah
I'm a little you know my hair is a
little darker than your back I can't
remember I think I think I kind of cuz I
had to clue him in because I thought
he's a break is hard to feel all of a
sudden then sees that wait a minute that
was a fraud yeah so I had to break his
heart and say no you have to keep
looking go down one trailer down there's
Gary rice right there well I get his
family I did Montana's fan mail on yeah
I I had a shopping bag full of mail
meant for him because some of these fan
magazines had somehow got a mailing
address for him yeah one for me but they
mixed them so because I went when I
eventually was able to talk to him which
I've done a couple times yeah he said
yeah I got a bunch of your mail to it so
I think we swapped you know shopping
bags so so maybe somebody they're
sending him hey you know I love you and
Godfather Part three yes my god you
might have got seven letters and I got
like 30,000
that's a difference between the you know
the goat of the flu you know of football
and and you know your work could they
act there but it's all good Joe Montana
here on the Rich Eisen show and then a
couple of your worlds colliding you have
played for a long time David Rossi now
the manager of the Chicago Cubs yeah how
about that
David Ross yeah I love that you think
you think your Cubs just put those two
things together
never know it could be serendipitous
well for the brakes if they can run
fifteen seasons numbers let's say for a
manager that would be amazing if David
Ross said okay run like the one you got
on Criminal Minds what do you think of
your new manager for the Cubs here you
know I'm hoping for the best my feeling
is he like talked about--we they say
what isn't a real managerial experience
I think hopefully what he'll lack in bet
he'll make up for enthusiasm and all
that and I got to know Madden a little
bit and you know and one actually one
little funny thing happened this past
season I'm a good friend with the
president of the Angels so good John
Carpenter we're big fans of Johnnie
Johnson he was talking on angels radio
right now well John John was a roommate
of one of my cousin's that's how we
first met years ago so anyway I've known
John for a long time right so anyway
last summer I had to they gave John an
award for being the magnanimous guy he
is and the Angels charity yeah so they
asked me to give the speech for him okay
so it was a day that the the Angels were
in Chicago and had beaten the Cubs it
was I think was a Saturday and they
beaten the Cubs and so I got up and gave
the speech and basically said even
though John's Angels beat my Cubs I'm
still happy because everybody booed me
because we're in Orange County
where I'm giving the thing but he gets
the phone call while I'm there cuz I'm
at his table
we're having dinner at the same table at
the event he gets a phone call basically
saying how the games rained out for the
they were gonna play mmm that day the
next day and and and and they needed to
pick a rain date and I guess the
visiting team has a choice of the rain
day hmm so John looks him he says what
are you gonna be in Chicago again I says
you know I said I'm gonna be there in
June I always go every June after
Memorial Day concert that I host what
would Gary Sinise I says I usually do a
cub game I throw out the first pitch he
goes what week I told him it was alright
he tells the guy goes
unless he goes can we do it June 3rd and
the guy goes yeah we can do June 3rd
grade so so now that's set so now I call
the Cubs the next morning and I said
look I said I've decided what game I
wanted to I want to do to June 3rd
angels game and the guy got on the phone
I'm gonna one of the guys up in the
office this is our we're not playing on
June 3rd I said oh yeah you are
[Laughter]
I said I don't think so I said just put
me down for the third like 2 hours later
I get the phone call playing the Angels
you know what can I tell you I got a
little inside info and now look who the
manager of the Angels is yeah it's nice
to tell you boy though you know what I
mean it's amazing yeah yeah I think he's
gonna be dynamite here Wren don't to to
go with trout and no Tommy he's healthy
I mean that's a hell no they said my two
teams you know and I gotta say I love
the soft spot for me because I ran in
this time Lasorda just about a month ago
and God bless him he's he's an old pal
too and he was my I did this movie
comrades the summer years ago I played a
baseball manager uh-huh and Tommy was my
mentor he kind of took me round all
weekend and yeah so he instilled in me
that you know that that thing for the
Dodgers as well so so Angels Dodgers
Cubs and a little bit yeah I gotta say
the Yankees cuz Lee Mazzilli is such a
dear friend of mine is Lily's dad was my
my piano tuner no kid I'm not I mean by
the way words that you never thought
that sounds like a mad lib right right
and from Staten Island New York
the I think Lee Mazzilli spa because I
remember when he came to tune the piano
in our house were like that's Lee
Mazzilli oh yeah no ill he was the man
and that's and I used to worry when I
first met him because I because when he
played for the Mets yeah and I'd be in
the bleachers at the cub games I'd be
swearing at him in Italian all these
Italian dirty words at him and I'll jump
cut like ten years later when I meet him
as you know and it's show business
environment and and I was afraid to I
thought he's gonna recognize my voice
he's getting
he's gonna know I'm that get that nut
instead I feel that women feel and I
finally said through my said Lee I gotta
tell you that was me out there that
would yell at you only he goes all
please Joe every time I was ever wrinkly
feel people were yelling at me I guess I
couldn't decipher who it would have been
so that's amazing
Joe Montaigne here on the Rich Eisen
show alright before we get to Criminal
Minds the famed sworsky Brothers sketch
yeah okay Saturday Night Live right it's
you George Wendt and Robert Smigel right
yes and and Mike Myers Mike Myers yeah
we did the original sketch thank you
from me so now okay so you're hosting
SNL right and then you go into a pitch
room or something like that
yeah Smigel who's not even from Chicago
he's from New York right but he knowing
that I was from Chicago and it was based
on football season and all he just came
up with this idea and the whole and of
course he'd been around all these so
many second city people work on hell
anyway yeah so he knew about the whole
Colbert's cult thing so he came up with
this idea of says hey I won't we do the
skit about da bears you know people
talking like BB I thought fantastic how
great is that
so we do that initial skit thinking okay
it's good one-shot deal would be fun to
people in Chicago get a kick out of it
the next day my phone is ringing off the
hook from people in Chicago saying hey
man they're playing your skit like on
the radio like on a loop they just it's
it's constantly playing and then next
time I go to Chicago they've got like
billboards up saying duh Bears the Bulls
the Cubs the you know your name it
everything was done everything so then
and then George went when is a post
thing to show a couple weeks later and
they figure well perfect we'll just make
him Joe's brother you know sorry I was
Bill Swirsky I guess and he was Bob's
George wasn't in the original you know
George was not in the original skit I
was the like I said I was the the the
the original skit right they did for me
was me Mike Myers Chris Farley and
Michael Farley because Farley's the one
who had the heart attack yes yes and
actually they made a movie they wrote a
moose Michael wrote a movie and it was
really wonderful and we were gonna make
the feature film it but that's what
unfortunately Chris Farley passed away
we're gonna make a feature film based on
the source keeper oh yeah absolutely
because if you think about it they did
the Coneheads movie
yeah so they had a movie we were
scheduled to do it Chris Farley passed
away and he was kind of the linchpin for
the film so what we wound up doing is we
wound up doing a versions of the the
film like for charity in other words we
would do readings of them we did it in
Chicago and we had Mike Ditka actually
come and do play himself and I think oh
yeah and this is such a perfect Ditka
story because we did it for charity yeah
and this was about us but maybe seven
eight years ago now
we're gonna do two performances like one
at six and one at nine and were sold out
yeah so you know we do what dick is
there for the six o'clock one we do it
it was great that goes out to dinner
with his wife he has a couple cocktails
he forgets to come back for the second
one and it was good so Mike I love Ditka
he forgets to come back so luckily there
was I think one of the pictures for the
white sox happened to be there i forget
who i read for Ditka and he stepped in
and read for dick his part but we did it
whence Michael was there went and I did
who did it yeah wonderful so George
Wendt hosted SNL couple weeks later and
they just they just morphed your skit to
include they just made him my brother
you're right his opening monologue was
hi this is Bob sworsky my brother bows
in the hospital because he had a heart
attack which is me and so every time he
would host it then and they'd relive
that skit he'd say Oh Bob Bobby still in
the hospital or I forget if I was bill
or bob whichever one I was then I wound
up I did do one more because I happened
to be in New York because they'd always
asked me to come back and do it with him
sure but I was always gonna be busy I
didn't kill California be making a movie
whatever I said look boys I'd love to
fly in and do you like job I got I gotta
live my life here but I did do one more
when I think Danny DeVito was hosting
the show and so George and I both came
in for it so me Danny George and I can't
remember which one that was but they
wound up doing that skit like I don't
know 15 20 times and we just had to veto
and here I had no idea here as part of
that I would have absolutely he did
then I gotta remember daddy bill he was
Bob just one more time swear I the way
it should you should do it again because
it still works I mean it's not like this
is aged oh yeah still work yeah and I
think people I think it's affected the
speech patterns of people in Chicago
because now that I think people they
look at the billboards and they think I
guess we're supposed to talk like that I
guess we place a dot instead of I think
I think that skin is effectively removed
the word dissolve from grammar schools
you know is teaching you know how to
speak in Chicago you know how do you say
th e da all right very good move on
[Laughter]
fantastic all right let's talk criminal
mind sir
when you first started it we nobody sees
13 years of a 15 year series right no no
it's just year three when you yeah I
came in the beginning of season 3 I was
hoping you know okay maybe get a season
or two out of this we'll see how it goes
right
you know no I mean the average show
probably last three seasons but you know
the it just kept going on I mean the
it's a testament to the to the
professionalism of everybody I mean the
writing staff is hugely important I mean
as the saying goes if it ain't on the
page it ain't on the stage you know and
so the writing was very important the
chemistry of the people and I think just
the subject matter I mean there's a lot
of procedurals out there there were
shows about evidence and cops and
robbers and you know how many bullets
hit the guy and this kind of stuff right
which is fascinating enough but we are
sure was a little different in that we
got into the the mental thing the
psychology in the psychic you know that
aspect of the criminal and I think that
appeal not just in the United States the
show is huge all over the world right I
did a lot of publicity a lot of us did
all over the world different countries
and we found out that it really
translated and a lot of women are women
made a big part of our audience and
probably because they're smarter than we
are
and second of all because they wanna I
think they were intrigued by yeah we
want to know what these people write
thinking and and you learn from it I've
gotten numerous emails from people to my
website that I'll say I just want to
thank you I don't know how to reach
anybody on the show but letting you know
there was an episode of Criminal Minds
that I remembered and I was in a
situation by and I learned from it
saved my life and little things like
that they don't expect you know that's
amazing yeah that's gotta be great to
receive it's great to receive it because
because we really did our best to
because it's a real organization wasn't
like we were like space group from Mars
type of thing we were the FBI the
Behavioral Analysis Group and they
really exist I've been to Quantico many
times and I have nothing but admiration
for these men and women that really do
that I'm not going unbelievable you go
there and you spend a little time there
and see what they're doing and you
realize wow if they had the time and
manpower to address every case that was
presented to them they would solve all
of it because it's that it's manure and
that much emphasis and work and work
ethic and all of that just tremendous
organization of nothing but respect for
them yeah and the 15 year run begins its
final season again Wednesday night
tomorrow night 9:00 Eastern Time
Thomas Gibson paget Brewster Aisha Tyler
who's been on the show I love her she's
phenomenal oh you should you know great
yeah yeah and more obviously I just just
name just a few
Joe you were the man I love having you
here I love being here rich thank you
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app